this is beautiful what tell me what
you're wearing I'm wearing Armani Prive
customer Oh
Armani what does it mean to be here and
have your rep your work recognized ten
years after you are last nominated yes
it's thrilling to be here and I'm full
of gratitude and I'm incredibly honored
it's a great room to be in and I will
have been an actress for 45 years this
this September
yeah it's supple to still be in the game
men's law yeah but if you have game you
stay in the game don't you don't you
think that is the truth and you have
done so many great roles it's good that
they're recognizing the wife because I
thought he was a fantastic movie thank
you thank you as you're making that how
much of it is nuance that you're
bringing to that role Oh a lot yeah a
lot because that role was very much
internal you know it was you she didn't
say a lot she was in the background and
a lot of it was on her face and so it
was it was I had to be alive inside and
know exactly in the context of the
character what she was thinking at each
time because it shows on camera very
powerful in Canada yeah we look at
someone like Carol Burnett who just
walked by who's getting honored tonight
the first time we've ever given the
Carol Burnett award yeah the first time
first time but what does it mean to
honor somebody you and I remember Carol
in her heyday we do and and how much
laughter she brought into the world I
mean just laughter with the iconic
people that were in her team and we need
laughter you know lord knows we need
laughter right now that you getting
pampered I know tell me about that
moment well I've just gotten a public
Instagram and it's kind of new to me I
had a private one and my dog has had one
for a while
sure Pippin of Beanfield and I'm kind of
liking it I'm think there'll be times
when I go underground and I won't say
anything but you know I think people
don't know what goes in to
actually stepping onto the red carpet
and the the those fittings and the
consultation and I'm wearing beautiful
look at this car wait a minute please
show that to show that off boom that's
actually a great Instagram I'm hoping
that I won't be able to get this off
they'll cut your finger trust me
[Music]